foreign
[Applause]
navigation is an exciting new feature
which allows one person to lay down a
trail of virtual waypoints someone can
then follow the route later on by
following the audio cues you can think
of this like laying down a trail of
breadcrumbs and following them later on
first of all let's switch to the world
channel if you're using a device with a
lidar you'll have buttons for filters
and actions and you'll find indoor
navigation inside the actions menu
actions button
on other devices you'll see indoor
navigation right on the main screen
indoor navigation button let's create a
new route let's get started by tapping
add add but seeing AI shows us a few
tips for how to create a route
you're going to walk with your phone
held upright to allow seeing AI to
capture visual information about your
environment but no actual video is being
stored
when choosing the route you're going to
walk try to keep to the edges of the
rooms rather than weaving through the
middle the technology works best when
there is visual contrast and not too
much reflection so try to avoid long
corridors with white walls or areas with
large windows and reflective surfaces
while it is absolutely possible for
someone who's blind to create the route
in this case we're going to get a
sighted colleague to do this
she's going to record the root on her
own device and send it to me later
let's create the starting point
we're going to place our first Waypoint
here
so we should be somewhere your colleague
will be likely to find it such as near
an obvious landmark
we're going to turn around to show
seeing AI the location from all angles
to make it easier to find it later
visually you'll see a blue Highlight
which you want to clear
you'll hear an audio tick each time you
clear a part of the area
keep showing seeing AI the location from
different directions building up and
down very slightly to get more angles
44 completed
100 completed
now seeing AI has captured visual
information
remember no pictures of the room are
saved
we can answer a name for the starting
point in this case we'll enter break
room let's also enter a note that the
starting point is next to the picnic
table
I am now going to walk along the route
to the coffee bar
now walk to the destination and tap end
route
as I walk seeing AI is creating
waypoints every couple of meters
as you can hear from that sound and the
ticks on the right
now that I've reached the coffee bar I'm
going to tap stop and enter a name for
the destination
in this case coffee bar but I'm not
going to add any notes this time
[Music]
now I'm going to share the roots
I'll just tap the roots and then share
alert follow share button
the route will be sent as a file
attachment
so I can choose any app which supports
sending files
for example I could use mail messages or
airdrop in this case I'll just select
messages
button
send button
send message
oh we just got a message there must be
the route messages now reader attachment
one file opening attachments in iOS can
be quite involved you may need to tap
open or even share multiple times until
you see a list of apps
sure
break room underscore coffee bar seeing
AI route then select seeing AI seeing
Aid button
seeing AI has been opened C alert
success
root imported successfully and the route
has been imported I'm going to select to
go straight to window navigation so I
can try it out Channel World preview
actions
indoor navigation button
break room to coffee bar button let's
select that break alert follow button
and tap follow
now we simply follow the audio cues
along the Route as we saw in the
previous video
I'm just following the waypoints
and there's the nice sound to tell me
that I've reached my destination
that's a really quick overview of vendor
navigation
this is really early technology and we
invite all feedback from the community
we want to know how you use this and how
we can make it better